[Music]
so
number three for me i went with a very
general thing but i do have some
specifics it was our trip to australia
and fiji that is my number one okay
so you have hit my number one good
gotcha and it's um it's that entire
trip and it's so hard
all of those moments are spectacular
that you've talked about there's so many
more
um you know i'll just shout out another
one which is
when we were uh when we went on
we went on the day trip uh you actually
weren't there uh yeah the day trip
outside of sydney and landon
we get off we're like um taking
taking some pictures this amazing
overlook and lando's like
dad how do you take a selfie
and i i i'm like well son you just take
the phone and then you hit that button
so it turns around this way so you can
see yourself
and then you just take it and i'm giving
it to him when he does it and like lando
takes his first selfie
so that's not the number one moment of
the year but it's a moment
that encapsulates the type of things
that you want to happen it's like
i ushered in my son's first selfie on an
overlook in australia now i just
it's funny that lando's hesitancy to
take pictures let pictures be taken of
himself
led to him being eight or however right
before he took
yes i got selfies of like non-talking
lock and shepard like just like picking
picking up the camera because he refused
he refused to have his picture taken
he wanted to be he wanted to be a ghost
now he
he he welcomes pictures being taken of
him i mean again that's another
quality another facet of that memory is
that
uh he's he's changed and developed
you know in terms of his self-confidence
that like there's all these things
wrapped up into this goofy
selfie that he took you know where he's
like
he's got that funny selfie look on his
face
um so yeah that i mean that
that whole thing that whole trip is my
number one
and it was just um man we've
you know we've carved out time in 2019
for us to have extended vacations
and we're kind of earmarking some of
that time and trying to figure it out
so i mean i it actually led to that like
okay we can
the let's go big well i can carve out
some time so it it well it creates it
shows you that
um i mean first of all the one of the
great things about travel is
because it shakes up your normal routine
it tends to be the thing that you
remember when you look back
because it broke you out of your
day-to-day right um
i even heard someone say man this was on
a podcast i'm sorry i cannot remember
who said it but it was great advice that
someone's dad said
giving financial advice there's only a
few things you should go into debt for
but one of those
should be vacation it's like don't
you can justify going into debt for a
family vacation which
yeah the eyebrows raised a little bit
right but it's like that's a provocative
thing to say
it is and that's why i said it but the
thing the thing that i have thought
about
this year is you know when i think about
the what i'm spending my money on
it wasn't the only there was there was
another thing i had i have thought that
like
this feels when we're paying for a trip
for paying to
i've got some exciting stuff i'll talk
about later because it's not happening
anytime soon
but paying for travel in my mind is
is i'm not going to coin a debt for it
but it's
justified i'm like you look at the price
tag but you're like yeah but i'm
creating this memory so
yeah i think it's definitely i don't
know what your number one is
better be good uh well my number one
is therapy is that it
yeah now therapy for me did not start in
uh 2018 it started the very very tail
end of 2017.
okay um i've talked about it a little
bit
um but the thing i mean again
uh i'm self-conscious anytime i talk
about it because i feel like it's one of
those
it's one of those really la things to
talk about and i know that we're out
here in l.a in this bubble and
you can kind of forget what um
it feels like to not be here yeah um
but interestingly uh
i would say that again it's kind of
very similar to what i was talking about
earlier that
you know you change so significantly so
quickly
when you're growing up uh and you're
going through
it's you think about how quickly our
children are
changing as they grow up and like we
haven't changed that much right you
change
in these dramatic ways you know both
physically but your brain is changing
and then
the way you see the world is changing
and then even in your
your your during your college time in
your 20s you're experiencing these like
just changes um in in
in your personal even in your
personality not
fundamentally your personality but just
different aspects and
i kind of feel like in a lot of ways um
up until i started kind of exploring
these things
with the help of a professional that
i kind of just assumed i was going to
kind of just be
me just be the same guy yeah for the
rest of your life you know i'm like
i'm pretty healthy in general i mean i
originally went to therapy
not because i thought that there was
something wrong with me
um in my in terms of like the way that i
see myself or thinking about myself i
went
because of the stress that what stress
was doing to me
the fact that i kind of let stress
affect me to the point that
it was affecting me physically and i was
like i just need somebody to help me
deal
like kind of deal with this i got help
with that
but i think that the sort of the the
breakthrough
for me or the beginning of a
breakthrough is when i started started
beginning to understand why i am the way
that i am like why
my personality is the way that i am the
way that it is why i'm so independent
and
um why i can uh
cry while watching
a commercial a lion king trailer like
literally
king i started watching first of all
you're not watching dogs on netflix
i don't know what you're doing uh you
should watch
dogs on netflix it's a document it's a
documentary series where they profile a
different dog and human relationship and
everyone
and i literally the first episode
started crying during the opening
credits and then i just cried the whole
time every day that's when they're
sacrificing cats like when the opening
credits well
and speaking of cats let me just say
right now
you could not make this documentary
about cats
okay hold on no no no we're talking
about your therapy let's get back to you
you couldn't make it
don't don't deflect into the world of
cat hate that was my fault
i challenge you to make a documentary
about the bond between
cats and people and all the wonderful
things these watch
dogs and then tell me that they could do
the same thing with cats they couldn't
unless you're about to cry let's bring
it back to you
um i'm in therapy for this for my cat
hatred
uh but it's interesting because
i cry really easily at certain things
like that but then
if you ask me things about and i had a
very i had a great
childhood i didn't i didn't experience
like uh
and um but like if you ask me about
things that like the
most difficult things that i experienced
growing up or whatever
i don't there's no i don't i don't
experience i don't i don't cry i don't
have
sadness about those things but i can
tell a story
about him and make somebody else cry but
yet
so i started learning that like i you
got your emotions have to come out in
some way
and so for me i'd i had found this way
to kind of deal with them by like i'm
going to watch this
documentary about dogs but yet not
deal with what's going on inside and
kind of it's
it's it's more it's more locked up
that's just kind of the surface level
talking about it but anyway
therapy has been significant for me
because it represents
sort of the beginning of a sort of a
second
journey in my life of kind of
going inside and figuring some things
out
i feel like i'm in the very beginning of
that
and there's a lot there's a lot of work
you hear people about talking about the
work
that they're doing and then you start
figuring out like oh
i need to be working on myself in this
way and it's not just about
some of the more obvious things which
we've we've both been doing which is
like
getting our schedule in order and making
sure that we've got things for the kids
which some of that has been really
assisted by therapy but they're like
what is it about me how can i
continue to grow and then how that how
does that then affect the relationships
that i have how does that affect how
what kind of father i am what kind of
husband i am what kind of friend i am
so that's been
that's number one no specific moment i
won't talk about like a moment in
therapy in which i had like a
a breakthrough i'll keep that your
private list between me and my therapist
but
therapy as a whole to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best